I'm gonna do the glasses yeah we'll do
glasses you just have to put this is
just gonna be the video we would never
see my pupils hey doing it's me that one
guy you probably don't watch me anymore
it's fine I'm still here though just
gonna I'm just gonna chat with you today
what's how do you do the 30 vlog start
again shall we I went to a party the
other day I went to my first party of
the year it was three days ago
hey I am a social butterfly I think you
could agree for a very long period in my
life I assumed that I didn't like
parties and rightly so because I went to
a fair amount of parties and I never
enjoyed myself there were drunk people
all around me encouraging me to be drunk
I did not want it I always wanted to sit
sit in the corner and play video games
that was always the highlight of any
party for me if I could find the
Nintendo 64 in the corner and encourage
whoever's it was to hook it up so I
could just place a Mario Cart that's the
kind of party I like to have there was
legitimately one house party that I went
to where I brought my Gamecube along
they're like oh we could like play
America together wouldn't that be fun
but I accidentally left my copy of Zelda
the Wind Waker in there
and spent the evening playing Zelda and
I had like a little audience of people
watching me as well that was the best
pie I finally came to the realization
though that it wasn't parties that I
didn't like I just never went to parties
with anybody that I liked and now I get
to go to parties with people I do like
and it's great they're very pleasant
that's a major realization in my life is
that parties can be fun well done
charlie got there eventually I even went
as far as to have alcohol at a party not
much at all I had like that much
champagne but to me it was a big deal I
was like this is not the Charlie that I
know but he's kind of fancy and maybe I
like him I still have absolutely zero
interest in getting drunk I don't
understand the appeal of that but as it
happens you can have a small amount of
alcohol and it makes you feel quite nice
so long as you're very sensible about it
another realization that everyone else
has already had but here I am having it
usually I plan these things intensely
very intensely I ran our whole script
but I'm too busy I'm doing films now
keeping up with the youtubers of today
daily vlogging and all that nope go go
do it gonna make eleven minute short
films instead
because that's nice and easy the film
internal make right now is proving to be
harder than the first one which was
deliberate I wanted to push myself but
turns out when he tries to do something
harder it's hard to well done just full
of revelations today aren't I but it
will be fine it's stressful but that's
what filmmaking is and I'm just the
thrill that I get to be doing it that is
all thank you for clicking on my face if
you liked this video I'm not gonna tell
you to click like you thought it was
coming didn't you
you thought if you liked this now if you
like this style of video let me know
because this was super easy to make my
god it's it's kind of nice not having a
script actually it's been a while since
I've done this but okay bye you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool that's funny I like
that one do more